peace be with you
welcome to the Dean show my next guests
an amazing and exciting show for you
today
native from France Bonjour to everybody
all of our French viewers we get a lot
of people tuning in from France born in
Paris then came over to the States lived
in Chicago and was an agent to the
underground stars his whole life
revolved around music and ate slept
music I saw he did was music promoted
music and today he's got an incredible
story turned his whole life around not
upside down made a 180 and he's here
with us today Antoine and we have an
incredible story for you don't go
anywhere we right back with my next
guest here on the Dean show
this is the now I know I must I said
Antoine Antoine and what about you how
do you pronounce it aunt when Antoine
Antoine dolly dolly will français oui
Monsieur yeah I know I mean there's a
big community in there is there is and
you know they're tuning in and they're
like how the law we have a native from
Paddy's mm-hmm you got the French that's
how you're gonna do that is that like
particular to answer to more British
what British yeah but people really knew
associated with well why do they
associate it with the French people you
know I guess you know is the barrier and
the baguettes and I don't carry them I
get to be me so we you have a very
interesting story you were agent to the
stars the underground stars Derrick
Carter and some of these other people
who were very well known DJ some of the
top elite deejays in the music world and
we want to kind of get of before and
after so tell us a little bit about
yourself and so we can kind of have the
audience identify with you and then
we'll get to where you're at today so
this man of mine are him so there's a
coherent first thank you so much for
having us me for having me here in China
we we I say we because it's my wife and
I actually traveling and we were just
going back to Chicago where I used to
live and that's where I reverted to
Islam 12 years ago at that time as you
were saying I was in the music business
I was bringing basically friends delays
to the US front DJs and musicians and on
there with the other way around as well
and um as you were saying music was my
life dance was my life I was spending
most of my time in nightclubs not for
drinking I wasn't drinking at the time
actually had quit drinking already but
to you'll be in that kind of frenzy
you know I guess and I'm you know
Chicago opened up its arms for me and so
I worked there for for a few years but I
guess I was also developing on the side
some you know I wasn't satisfied
completely of course I was looking for
something else and even though I was
physically involved in a lot of things
spiritually something was missing
there's a big void you could say there
was a void isn't French known for now
being a you you know people go to France
for that romance and it's kind of linked
to you know you get away you got French
wine French women and it's just kind of
like you know the big party and friends
romance is this kind of just correct
there's a part of it that's correct this
still has to no big fantasy fantasy
that's what it is people create a
fantasy around French from the French
language and but you I mean obviously
you were living at that whole lifestyle
and you weren't happy
no and I grew up also I was lucky enough
to travel I lived in other cities I
lived in London and lived in Hong Kong
I'd seen your other parts of the world
and I you know for me it all eventually
goes to the same materialistic view of
things you know our world today is just
the same pretty much everywhere yeah so
even this fantasy about friends you know
when people get to Paris they understand
that it's no more you know no
unfortunately is that the the is it the
French president also who was kind of
also just chasing his desires is that
the one and he was hiring prostitutes
and is that the French president or
which this one maybe not you know I can
so overtly yeah but you know yeah these
politicians they're kind of getting
caught with you know yeah oh yeah
dodging you know talking about yet with
the post president of the I am
okay yes okay which is--what's-- gonna
be the next player is gonna be the
negation yeah yeah yeah so you see
people I mean indulging in their desires
you you were you know living numbing
their minds with you know either drugs
or alcohol yes I was in the middle of
that yeah I had some clarity because I
wasn't taking any drugs or drinking but
I guess another way of numbing yourself
is you know through any kind of
addiction and music to me was an
addiction thence to a certain extent was
an addiction as well I had to have that
you know that in a rush you know like
you can let me get in sports or you can
get so I was kind of hooked on that and
you know I alas I was well made it so
that I get injured actually I got
injured I couldn't perform what I was
doing before I was how did you get
injured doing martial arts so you do
you've done martial arts also yes cop
where capture right yeah and I was
pretty poor here yeah so you get injured
now was it it was a kind of a match that
you had or just during some regular
anywhere just doing training okay yeah
and you know as something snapped I
clean my back I guess I had to you know
take a rest for a long time and it
happened so that at the same time I met
this brother here Farid who you know I
was they know sending my biggest Salaam
because you know his today it's still my
biggest friend my best friend so you met
a Muslim now I met a Muslim yeah okay
he's a French Algerian okay but before
that were you involved in any kind of
religion not much I was looking at
different philosophies mostly Eastern
you know or like Buddhism Taoism yeah
was more into that yeah you mentioned
before I think that you you you weren't
the the whole there's kind of a negative
thing attached to religion people don't
want to be associated with any organized
religion exactly that at the time when I
met this brother that was what really
struck me you know it was someone was
very free very himself who know himself
very well who had a knowledge about a
lot of things was very smart and we had
a lot of conversations together and you
know he was taking me to other levels
really and
ilysm but at the same time he was
following what i called at the time
organized religion
which for me was nothing but constraints
and you know like shutting doors to your
yet to your spirit or to your intellect
so for me that was a big paradox at the
time yeah is it in French what's the
predominant religion there now today
today some people say it's Islam shall
be Islam
yes because there's a very large
population of Muslim in France and
unfortunately you know the Christian
community doesn't practice anymore the
churches are empty the churches are
empty yes in very much and I've heard
the same thing in UK and many others
yeah
European countries that the churches are
empty yeah why do you think this is well
you know they got caught in into that
individualism this materialistic world
and they don't see any interest in those
traditions anymore and on the other hand
the mosques are flowe the mosque are
spinning over the streets you know which
causes trouble sometime but because we
don't we're not given enough enough room
to pray for instance on Friday prayers
for instance so yeah people wait on the
streets the Mongols are full yeah yeah
we're crammed
you know yeah so how do you go from from
not wanting to follow any organized
religion and then you come to Islam so
first because of that meeting with his
brother
you know that's idea that set idea that
I had in my mind was slowly changing you
know I could tell there was something
else in Islam that actually provided him
with the right basis the right structure
for him to blossom you know this in
every direction that's what Islam is all
about gives us this strong basis
basically and then on the other side so
that was more like knew like the
intellectual side of things they already
call and then I also started feeling
very you know like different pains in my
body and at the time I talked about it
to his brother
and he said maybe you know Islam can do
something there for you as well
and that's where I started actually
having in Rokia done on me that's the
healing with the we're healing with the
you can actually do that yes yes yeah
and for me that was you know very very
strong because the first time I actually
heard the Quran I didn't speak a word of
Arabic it was someone actually he had
brought in so I didn't know him I was
sitting on a chair
he started reciting and I started
shaking yeah and I start actually moving
the way like he was telling me to in
Arabic but I couldn't you know
understand a word yeah it had profound
effects on me like physically
emotionally aesthetically as well I
could feel something in my heart opened
up at that time and this you know that
it was just something very beautiful
that was just coming to my heart that
was touching my heart and you know from
that on then on I was I was hooked I
guess you know I could tell that I
needed to go and and dig further in that
direction so that has never left me
since since then basically we're gonna
take a break right now what you can do
is actually type type in if you're close
to a computer look type in qur'an
recitation' and just listen to these
words powerful you might not understand
them but you will feel the effects
definitely Quran recitation and you can
see if you can identify with what he was
talking about and we'll be right back
with more to talk to our brother all the
way from Paris we'll be right back with
more here in a teashop
it's like when did you think that you
had no purpose
are you worthless the value comes from
purpose your purpose in life is to
worship the Creator nor worship your
desires himself not worship social
pressure the celebrity culture but
worship the thing that's much higher and
transcendent above and beyond by
worshipping God and seeking his pleasure
you get pleased so you have double
pleasure
back here on the Dean show with Anthony
and proper pronunciation or proper way
to say this name is and when on Tuan anh
Tuan
okay so Antoine now nowadays you see
that that when we mentioned religion you
know people have this distance they
distance themselves from any organized
religion and then you mentioned
something about the Quran you it had
this effect effect on you now
many people don't know that you know
Islam really calls you to think to use
your mind you know it's a thinking man's
way of life you know this Quran pondered
you to think you know the Creator is
challenging mankind if you say that this
book is from other than the crater find
one discrepancy contradiction as and the
other man-made religions you will see
contradictions things that you know
don't add up so people just leave
religion all together you said that now
that this the Quran had a profound
effect on you and you went further was
there it was there was their mental
Intel intelligent stimulation that came
after this that when you looked into it
mmm
of course you know but I was at the time
I wasn't speaking Arabic so we going
through translation and I must emphasize
here how important it is to learn Arabic
I was actually for a long time I've been
struggling with it because of the effect
it had on me you know it was hard for me
to open up the Quran I could feel you
know I could feel basically its power I
guess you know it's healing power so it
was very much anyway like in a room
where we'd be learning Arabic or
listening to Quran I would have to leave
would be too much if people were
reciting around me you know I had this
profound effect on me so of course I
could tell you know even though that at
the time it was only like a physical
thing but I could tell of course the
world was were powerful words yeah so
and all of this you know went further
after that two or more you know like
again I started learning about my Dean I
was able to access this theological
Institute in Paris and you know learn
about all we know about the Serie about
laughs of the prophets of Allah solemn
but fear about you know Arabic
eventually and then so yeah eventually I
get to the point of course where you're
able to you know open up any page of the
Quran and learn something that is useful
for you in your life today it has been
applied very like a practical
application and listen how did you deal
with all the negative stereotypes and
the Islamophobia many people there
searching for truth you know they want
troof and if truth comes to them if they
can buy it they would pay for it you
know what I mean but nowadays as soon as
you say Islam there is some negative
stereotypes and we know all of this
stuff is just false propaganda that
indeed Islam is this way of life from
the crater submission to the will of the
one who made you your maker the maker of
mankind you know the same way of life
that Jesus knows and all the messages of
God they call people to worship this one
God so now you know you have people
especially in France a lot of Islamic
obeah yes how do you how do you deal
with this how did you deal with this
you're still dealing with I'm sure yes
of course we still very much concern
although we've left you know friends a
few month ago now but you know this is a
home this is my country this voice I was
born this is where all my family is from
so it's it's very painful just painful
to have my religion being portrayed like
this my you know fellow-countryman
having a very negative view for most of
them and my family even you know it's
it's hard it's hard because it's not any
more than intellectual you know level
that dimension that where things can be
discussed you know it's actually hard to
discuss you know you mentioned God in
France and the doors are down so it's
very hard to actually have a
conversation about God yeah I mean do
you think now if people didn't have this
myopic vision they weren't so
narrow-minded and you can actually get
in to talk because people are obviously
you can see like when people when you
start talking about God being a man that
he died and many of these beliefs that
just don't make sense
and you can't figure it out and I'm sure
fresh people are intelligent people
forever so so now I think most of this
came from man-made religions organized
by man mmm but now you know the door
shut but a lot of people are losing out
because I'm sure if they heard about
Islam and it's the rational teachings
and you know the way that Islam is the
antidote for many of the all of the
social exactly yeah it's again as I was
saying today it's hard to challenge this
on a like intellectual dimension level
it has to be more for us first as being
you know the best example that we can be
you know Dawa starts with behavior with
how your character is and we very much
emphasized you know our life and our
behavior to be the best person that we
can be that that allows us to have like
further indiscretion and go deeper into
every people like you know kind of lift
off a few barriers that people have you
know a few that of those gates that I
put they've been putting in front of
them so that's probably right now in
France how it is today I would say for
most people yeah okay so now you have
all these religions in Islam obviously
you're gonna get the most trouble
practicing it you know you're gonna get
the most resistance so you have
Christianity you have Buddhism and a lot
of times if you practice these no one's
gonna say none to let's go ahead yeah
why'd you choose Aslam yeah that's what
I tell all the reverts I call them in
reverse or converse that I meet you know
how can you choose Islam maybe look at
the news do you know what this lamb is
no it's just it goes so far beyond that
you know that I guess you know a lot of
it cannot be explained you're just
taking on this journey I'm taking on a
journey I don't control anything here
you know Eliza was actually you know
burned me here I was born and raised in
a place in France where there's very
little Muslim I couldn't access any
knowledge about Islam to come here in
the u.s. 2001 you know when people hear
that they well so your moment and place
you know and have to come here to
basically found out about it so I'm
trying the best that I can to you know
Express Who I am
first of all I think that's the most
important thing and Islam is the best
tool by far you know in the most perfect
and the perfect tool to be who you are
on all levels on all dimensions and I
guess from their own you know you can
again trying to set an example trying to
reach out with that behavior to to other
people of course not you know never
evading any kind of any confrontation
you know we're both we take part into
like interfaith dialogue we take part I
am on the field you know I'm a
humanitarian worker so we do meet a lot
of non Muslim that we go and help and of
course they have questions and of course
they will talk about Islam but it's hard
to like confirm directly today in in
France
it's different here you know people are
more open-minded here people you know I
still got believing here yeah so you can
talk about God but yeah it's hard to
even mention the world girls got some
time in France yeah I think people like
you know most people that we talk to and
we have this 1-800 number 1-800 number
then people call and some people will
call sometimes aggressively but after
you know they calm down and they start
thinking rationally and we start to
explain Islam to them mmm oh um just
makes sense
mmm it's Lamas not calling you to blind
belief as you obviously know Islamic it
provides the evidence it's authentic
it's providing you know the thinking
person is there a lot of atheists in in
France yeah it probably is the first
religion we really I mean according to
our belief we don't believe there's
strictly someone who's purely atheist
everyone believes in God yes yeah
believing nothing is already believing
something uh-huh you know it's already
beliefs there so you just have to work
on how find the right words also you
know we're missing a lot of the right
words and friends to being in French you
know to be explained about Islam a lot
of people are just ignorant it's mostly
ignorant yeah so that's the first thing
and and then the second thing really is
having a you know that's broader view of
how
let's yeah being in your environment
being the best that you can and setting
an example and trying to be you know
Islam has taught me that that I can have
a very critical mind about what's
happening around me it gave me those
tools and how to analyze the society I
mean the the environment and I mean and
trying to bring solutions and it's true
for me that example in trying to bring
solutions and they're gonna say hey this
guy you know he has a few ideas that
maybe not that could be interesting for
everyone and where does he take this
from Islam from from you know from the
sonorous also a nice element from the
Quran yeah we're gonna take a break and
then we have some more questions before
we come to an end obviously you know
people were out there and depression is
on the rise you know you know suicide
and people have money but many people
are unhappy are you happy definitely and
if you didn't know I mean Jesus was a
Muslim Abraham was a Muslim all the
message that the crater sent well this
is one who submitted to the Creator not
the creation they didn't worship
anything but the one who created
creation that just makes sense we'll be
right back with more here with Anton
Oakland here everybody in deep down they
believe that there is a God yes and as
much as they deny
if God exists and he does if God sends
prophets and he does if God reveals
books and he does should he not tell me
how to live my life doesn't that make
sense they feel more secure and safe now
inside the religion of Islam than they
ever felt out in the streets
but the best way to bring true profound
happiness trooper found peace trooper
found tranquility is by following the
guidance that God has given see for
yourself what Islam has to say because
it really is the path to happiness and
truth in life
back here on the Dean show before we
went to break I was mentioning some
facts not fiction that suicide is on the
rise people have technologies on the
rise but depression is also mm-hmm and
people are listening to music numb in
their minds and when you want to bring
up let's say this serious topic what's
the purpose of life have you thought
about this important question at that
time you know you had obviously money
agent to the stars underground stars you
were you know indulging in your desires
I mean there was a point where you're
probably not even this question if
someone asks you purpose of life it's
far from thinking about it or enjoying
it like just enjoying it have been ate
probably so if someone asks you look
that life is short just get all you can
right now because that's it it's done
just guess yeah what would you say Tom
well so today you know now that you know
that you know the different take on
things yeah life is short you know every
breath counts and every breath today
actually in our cities even it's hard to
breathe
you know this even gets hard today
everything is done for us not to be able
to have that connection you know that's
spiritual connection whether it is
through remembrance just remembering and
how can we not remember who created all
this you know going a little further in
our reflection all this is given to us
at any minute every breath is given to
you it's a blessing every piece of food
every you know every step you take is a
blessing in this world and how can you
not be thankful for that basically how
can you just you know think okay all
these people you know talk about the
energy going through or you know this
everlasting thing goes around but this
has a creator to all this you know it
has to go back to the Creator you have
to go this step this one step further
higher to the creator of all things and
be thankful to him because he's the one
who created all this you cannot be
thankful to all this this is creation
this is
the Creator so that would be probably my
that's where it starts being grateful
and thankful no not being too proud to
turn to the one who created you and to
thank him for all the breath that you
mentioned that we breathe that's a
blessing
mmm people right now they can just hold
their breath see how long you can last
not your you can't yeah gives you all
this but we don't even think about this
we are as we were saying numbed but not
only by music we are numbed you know in
the city life also we're numb by TV
we're number all those Queens you know I
don't haven't had a TV for 10 years more
than 10 years when I go to someone's
place I'm totally hypnotized by it so I
can tell it's a powerful tool very
powerful tool the media right and just
discrete yourself because you'll be
looking you know your it's your
reptilian brain I go and see movement
and light that's all it needs and then
is get this distracted
yeah that's distraction right there
that's already like starting to worship
something else trying to you know you're
just fascinated by something that's not
a lot about yeah so for me yeah that's
that our society today has a a lot of
struggle ah'd of you know traps so
someone says how can you give up music I
mean people go to sleep to music alarm
to music you know that's all they they
think about you know making a new CD put
in a car blast in it and just you don't
think about this reality the purpose of
life you know and going beyond the the
partying the playing and amusement mmm
so what if someone's tell how can you
live without music you know I was I was
right there I was just having music 24
hours a day and I quit like this you
know from one day to the next
actually I threw all my records you know
it wasn't very transitioning but I had
to you know make room basically so I did
and and you know hamdulillah I feel so
much better and that he leads me to just
other places now this is where the
silence is important you know where you
can hear yourself think
hear you think just be able able to
connect with with a lot of them that's
why we're traveling now actually yeah
you know a lot of people can't do that
they can't bear to be by themselves mhm
because a eternal pain kicks in
yeah they have to be around
people-people they have to be in the pub
in the bar drinking taking some
substance because there's a void and
they're filling it with the wrong things
you noticed that very much so and I'm
trying today to fill it with the right
things basically that's what we're
trying to do them fill it with what the
medicine that the crater is giving us
yes you know just all around us
yeah it's all around it and especially
in nature that's my big thing now is to
go the way we're traveling now so we
know told you we are we run had actually
when my wife and I we're traveling to
Nexus Hajj touring around the world
meeting a lot of mothers you know
brothers and sisters and also spending
time in those places where they call
organic farms yeah where people they're
you know they're very close to Islam
mashallah because that that direct
connection with allah azza wajal
you know and they're very much there and
i think first it's one of the main
solution is out there actually in those
places in that kind of lifestyle because
what's coming today you know as far the
economic crisis as far as social crisis
everything is coinciding right now I am
an in the cities is weak when we go out
you know it it gives a full other
meaning basically to what were able to
practice to pray in nature to have your
you know your forefront forehead on the
ground and the earth it's nothing
variable to be appreciating you know the
the Creator by looking at his wonderful
creation exactly isn't it you just get
an elaborate gas all of its you know
people's you know he created us in
different tribes so that we can meet
each other
that's what's them in the Quran you know
and and that's what we're doing really
over
so now before we leave you're also
traveling the world with your wife yes
and you started now and your destination
final destination God willing is where
Makka mecca hugs you so much to the
first house of worship built by Abraham
in Seoul oh yeah yes Adam even even
going back further so that your that's
your destination now I'm going to travel
the world amazing from you know we
started in France Europe Iceland
Greenland the u.s. inshallah South
America and then New Zealand in South
Australia in Seoul
three agents online then to make it yeah
beautiful we got to go now
but there was also I forgot to mention
the beginning of the show there's a
famous UFC Ultimate Fighting
Championship fighter Georges st. some
tears fps now you guys you speak the
same language with many of the you know
you said like look now we've got a lot
of people's attention they're listening
and we hopefully we can get him this
someone get it to him and for all the
other French people now what would you
now that the door is open what would you
encourage them to do so to infrared to
George yeah I love the results of
Monterrey see you the donessa drones the
velocity the Wawa and coho in energy
keep em attracted search was admirably
extraordinaire Jacob up the long way you
see a tattoo mom Oh Satan earlier le pas
and Zappa champa an Uzi Dhoni a with
average humidity but at several places
they occur at mimosa be partyi equipos
de peche a it was Depeche Li thus
happily a dramatics it was good Manju do
not publish on the Korea would say you
can you don't look as soon as I played
so rapidly
Poonam Vinick Montano from London a
leprosy detail exit ER I'm gonna call
Mia inshallah beautiful God willing that
message gets to him and everyone else
that understands the French language
thank you for being with us here in the
Dean shows it's like a lot yeah thank
you so much thank you now it's a very
important topic you know that many of us
were neglecting purpose of life why
we've been created and we shouldn't have
apathy towards this we should really
think about it and you want to model
someone after someone who's successful
someone who's made a billion or a
million and you look ok how they get
there so how did this person that live
from music that was an agent to the
stars who just engrossed himself in
materialism
now he came to this wonderful way of
life that's based on reasoning logic
let's put aside all of this these callow
and just senseless arguments that are
made by people Islam we we obviously
know has nothing
do with all these things that are
affiliated with it get to know it from
the source
meet a Muslim ask these important
questions and really use your mind that
the Creator has given you and weigh it
out it's easy to close the door on this
but open the door up and see what's
behind that door really get to know this
way of life that is from the crater it's
not an organized religion by man or men
but it's organized by the one who
created man and woman and everything in
creation the one who created creation
and I guarantee you without a doubt it
will bring that peace that you're
looking for into your heart it'll be a
new beginning a new start follow us on
Facebook or like us on facebook follow
us on twitter and tune in every week to
the deen show and let's just I mention
that suicide and the antidepressants you
know are on the rise the the the
pharmaceutical mark companies are making
millions on people's depression but why
stay depressed I'll start right now
leave you with some homework look ask
your Creator to guide you real simple
not a man not a woman not the creation
but raise your hands up prostrate the
way that Jesus prostrated and asked the
crater alone that just makes sense
what's internally built inside you is
identifying with this ask the Creator
alone to guide you establish a direct
connection even the stars such as Oprah
Winfrey and many of these billionaires
they meditate they meditate daily 10 to
20 minutes in the morning ten to twenty
minutes and at night to awaken this the
spiritual side in them but you can do
something even greater than that take
time to thank your crater for all the
blessings for the air that you're
breathing right now and all the
countless blessings that you get
throughout the day too many too many to
to enumerate on so thank him and ask him
for guidance let's start there don't let
this program end and after it you're
being hypnotized by the by the boom box
and the TV do it right now
and we'll see you next time here in the
den show until then peace
be with you